i wanna talk about legends never die
because you've got a legend
working with you on it
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a very interesting thing for me
because obviously i'm like
such a fan of shania like all of us are
and
uh it was extremely interesting to be
you know in such close proximity with
her when we worked on the song and we
worked on the video
you know she's such a kind person and
she's so she's so incredible and so warm
that uh
she made it really easy though but i
think i had to keep kind of reminding
myself
like oh like don't forget don't forget
to like
perform in the video and that kind of
stuff because you know obviously you're
standing next to shania twain you can't
help but be pinching yourself a lot
[Applause]
what does she like to work with is she
very hands-on she's incredibly involved
in everything she's
done for her whole career which i was
like so thrilled to learn and to talk
with her about because i'm very similar
you know i'm very hands on with all
aspects my videos my the songs
everything and she's very much the same
and so that was really cool that uh you
know she to learn that she had been so
involved with everything that she's that
she's done
she's incredibly easy to work with super
professional really hard working just
wants to do like take after take like
she's
she's amazing i can't say a single bad
thing about shane and she's just great
legends
i'm reading the reviews of show phony
it's like people can't say a single bad
thing about this
it's like you're getting a claim across
the board
how would you describe this versus
what pony sounded like i think this is a
slightly more
confident uh approach to some of my
songwriting perhaps i mean i'll always
love pony and uh
you know but i think now that i had the
encouragement of um
seeing the success of pony and kind of
it gave me the confidence to be able to
just go
further with everything and maybe maybe
go to the places that i might have even
held back a little bit
on pony and there's still no
rest the reign of glory in the west
you have a name for the mass that you're
wearing today you know what this one's
brand new i haven't named it yet you
want to name it
i mean and so i always give them girls
names well so far
uh right well i don't know my daughter's
name is naomi has naomi said
i love that i mean i think that's quite
suiting because you know it's like
it's like naomi campbell and this one's
quite like uh
done up so that's perfect it's naomi you
got it you named it